[музика]
не поширеніше питання ви знаєте яке
проїдає чи коли в нього через нього
висилатимуть судові та воєнкоміські
поїздки завдання щоб до кінця цього року
громадян Було відчуття що вони більше
там або мінімально взаємодіють з
державою тому що все можна отримати
електронному форматі Я за ізобетона
впевнений що потрібно дати свободу
підприємцям Вони все зроблять Тобто
мілітерітек - це можливо майбутнє нашої
цифрової економіки тобто ідея наша в
тому що взагалі прибрати людські фактор
Я не вірю що можна побудувати якусь
інституцію з судженнями
людськими яка буде не корумпована в
цьому напрямку про електронну демократію
під час війни нові послуги для цивільних
та військових а також привілеї для тієї
галузі Ми сьогодні говоритимемо звідси
прем'єр-міністром міністром цифрової
трансформації Михайло федоровим вітання
е-е минулого місяця Ви дуже так гучно чи
не святкували відзначали триріччя роботи
дії порта фінансових послуг і мобільного
застосунку багато говорили про здобутки
дійсно він став Незамінним за останній
рік війни для українців ми говорили
багато по досягнення з вашим заступником
паном онлайн А от що ви вважаєте
все-таки чи могли би назвати теплом чи
недоліками цього проекту Ну звичайно що
хочеться рухатися ще швидше тому
у нас завжди є таке амбітний план і в
принципі ми його намагаємося виконувати
але хочеться ще більше проектів
реалізовувати тому що розуміємо час
швидко минає всі країни також
розвиваються нам потрібно боротися за
громадян класним сервісом тому напевно
помилки є в кожному проекті можна там
багато про це говорити Ми постійно їх
аналізуємо і виправляємо Це найголовніше
але темп хочеться постійно рухатися
швидше і тому ми там робимо постійні
організаційні зміни як стелю менеджменті
пробивати щоб запускати там не 4-5
послуг на місяць я запускати 20-30
ви намагаєтеся до кінця року я Якщо я не
помиляюся цифрувати їх всі
раніше казали не найпопулярні Просто всі
послуги неможливо відшифрувати напевно
тому що вони постійно виникають якісь
там під послуги є як їх ідентифікувати
але в принципі завдання щоб до кінця
цього року громадян Було відчуття що
вони більше там або мінімально взаємодії
з державою тому що все можна отримати в
електронному форматі коли готувався до
цього інтерв'ю у всіх питають ну
непоширеніше питання ви знаєте яке
продає да чи коли по нього через нього
розсилатимуть судові та воєнкоміські
поїздки не плануємо цього робити не
працюємо над цим тому відповідають
традиційно
Ну я думаю що там є багато
організаційних питань чому так не можна
робити тому що наприклад
ще неякісні реєстри
військовозобов'язаних і буде
справедливість коли за того що
інформації немає в електронному реєстрі
або є людина отримує або не отримує
повістку Тому потрібно працювати з
якістю даних а після цього думати про
сервіси це не та сфера де можна походу
там щось покращувати потрібно Тому що
тут це досить сенсативне питання І це
буде негативно точно впливати на
розвиток цифрової держави тому у нас
немає цього питання взагалі сьогодні На
порядку денному разом із тим ви б
занурились цифровізацію військового
обліку працюєте зараз з в еука наскільки
військовому комісії
наскільки от військові випускають
цивільне Міністерство своєї реєстри Ми
допомагаємо допомагали до цього
ізобарігом це інформаційна система для
військовозобов'язаних і зробили там
навіть
багато прогресу скажемо адапторгнення це
було пов'язано з зі зміною місця
реєстрації ми запускали зміну реєстрації
почали віддавати оновлену інформацію яка
якраз цю інформа електросистему це з
раніше був обов'язковою метою обліку
військкомату перед розумінні реєстрації
а ми змінили філософію тому що має ми
зробили повну річ послуги і ми просто
почали передавати цю інформацію в цей
реєстр там без перевірки і тим самим е-е
запросили можливість взагалі е-е цієї
послуги як змінили місце реєстрації це
до речі найпопулярніша послуга в нашій
країні і довідка про місце реєстрації ми
це завдання вже виконали тому ми тут
тоді доторкнулися до цього питання щоб
ви розуміли воно не тільки в полі там як
якісно наповнити цей реєстр там
налагодити процеси поповнення даних і
так далі вони навіть стосувалися того що
є архіви паперові інформація про
військове зобов'язаних і немає
комп'ютерів не було військкоматах для
того щоб люди просторбували цю
інформацію і з не був не було захищених
периметрів і так далі і тоді ми
торкнулися не тільки питання як
організаційно побудувати наповнений
реєстр А ще як забезпечити комп'ютерами
доставити там ноутбуки захист периметру
і так далі і тому ми Е Там завдяки там
скажемо вже навіть не Міністерства
оборони це купували передавали там через
різні фонди е-е тому є багато чого ще
зробити наскільки ваше питання наскільки
да е-е нас чекають в цьому напрямку
скажу так що постійно
запити нашу допомогу тільки збільшуються
Не зменшується Ось така тенденція є я
пам'ятаю як в 2019 році презентував ще
навіть виявити тоді ще не було
членом уряду ще був просто частиною
команди президента Зеленського і розмову
йшла під час цифровізації зрештою про
електронну демократію в дії зараз працює
інструмент опитування ви його ви їх
почали проводити все частіше і частіше з
доволі сенситивних питань
принаймні політичних сентивних Як ви
вважаєте наскільки
репрезентативною і результати цих
опитувань і коли ну запрацюють вибори
через дію умовно кажучи почну з кінця
питання про вибори е-е ними вирішуємо це
вирішує
наша
ЦВК Центральна виборча комісія потім
Верховна Рада після цього там ну тобто
там до цього слова думка коли цього буде
політично
систему судову систему не буде такого
високої високого рівня довіри до
Верховної Ради всіх інституцій державних
і правоохоронних просто не потрібно
цього робити тому що це може призвести
там до недовіри населення і Ну до
якихось соціальних криз тому таке
питання також сьогодні На порядку
денному Вона стоїть
Ми тому розвиваємо деякі елементи
прямого електронна демократії тому що це
без альтернативний розвиток суспільства
всі країни будуть розвивати елементи
електронної прямої демократії всі будуть
всі роблять петиції вони також там в
свій час будуть в дії точно ми
опитування запускаємо що до
репрезентативності Я просто соціолог
тому можу сказати що навіть
презентативно звичайно але це масове
опитування велика кількість
респондентів і тому все
тенденції скажемо суспільства вони там
можна відслідкувати завдяки опитування А
для цього і потрібні опитування вони
допомагають просто допомагають ще одна
точка зору на яку можна спиратися при
формуванні політики Я в цьому не бачу
проблем бачу тільки можливості і ми
людей по суті показуємо людям як як може
працювати пряма електронна демократія
показуємо що не потрібно там не знаю
витрачати свій час і ти можеш там
впливати на рішення держави тобто до нас
це таки певний Пілот MVP не знаю там е-е
розвитку електронної демократії умовно
кажучи результати опитування дії зараз
можуть стати основою для проекту
документу але не для зміни якогось
серйозного політичного Я думаю що це
може бути також вагомою думкою тому що
це наше громадяни якщо 2 млн громадян не
важлива до кінця репрезентативної і яка
похибка 2% або 5%. якщо два е-е 2 млн
українців проголосували за певне рішення
це може бути і вагомою точку зо на
певного законопроекту навіть не тільки
нормативно-правового акту Кабміну щодо
сторінки ви минулої весни якось замкнули
насильно собі цю комунікацію з цією
компанією можете У вас є розуміння
скільки Україна витратила на сторінки і
витрачаючись дуже просто е-е нуль в
Україні зараз 42000 сторінки в 38-40
тисяч тільки вони всі всі сторінки які
партія отримала Україна Вона отримала
через нашу команду яка співпрацює з
урядами інших країн
компанія spacex забезпечує логістикою
партнери допомагають фінансовому
отриманому спеціальну ціну Ми
продовжуємо комунікувати З компанії
spacex вирішити всі проблеми які походу
виникають тобто
в цю в цьому питанні в нас також є чітке
розуміння повертаючись ви сказали що не
токаючись військових А якщо торкатися
військових місяців тому була заява про
те що spacex обмежить використання
сторінки в Україні військовими що це за
обмеження ви вже розумієте і чи вдасться
їх скасувати як вони будуть працювати
Давайте так з роботиспособлення зі
сторінки немає сьогодні
проблем Вони працюють всі функції які
вони виконували вони виконують
тому в цьому напрямку все під контролем
і все буде І все буде добре що ж мав на
увазі список студію Я думаю що
компанія в цьому питанні Вона може
тільки
призвести до негативних наслідків зараз
все працює і воно буде працювати як
довго А як довго наскільки я впевнена що
стільки скільки нам це потрібно для
перемоги
окрімської
влаштували справжні марафон Минулого
року перемовин з світовими it-геантом ви
намагалися
добитися цифрової ізоляції Росії це ну
не можна сказати що це вдалося мабуть на
100% багато великих компаній продовжують
працювати в Росії з іншого боку
українські користувачі які як відомо
завжди і скаржаться продовжують
скаржитись що їх дописи про війну в
Україні блокуються такими платформами як
в Facebook ще Twitter чому так
відбувається
працює вся ця індустрія перемовин багато
компаній які за MasterCard дійсно
покинули там PayPal
фігман багато там безліч компанії
покинули Росію дійсно ми постійно
аналізуємо слідкуємо які компанії
продовжують через інші там вірусоби або
там е-е
вони там продали компанія продали вони
компанії точно чи ні тобто ми постійно
це шукаємо цю інформацію для того щоб
потім декомуніковувати і не відпускати
це питання і так потрібно робити В
кожній сфері що стосується блокування
деякого контенту Ну якщо ми говоримо про
мед то дійсно зараз е-е ситуація
покращилася там я це відчуваю тому що
всі запити приходили до нас тому я
відчуваю по кількості Запитів У нас є
пряма комунікація з компанії Meta велика
там скажемо таки переломний момент було
був коли вони розблокували сторінка
Азову ну тобто перестали блокувати за цю
інформацію коли вони верифікували
верифікували офіційні сторінки Азову там
в фейсбук Instagram і зараз вони
постійно покращують алгоритм щоб
уникнути блокування там де можна
уникнути за те що українці іноді
емоційно висловлюються але справедливом
повністю висловлюється Це досі працює на
рівні алгоритмів так вони в них там
Звичайно що є якась частка і ручного
модерування але все Проблема була в
алгоритмах І зараз я не бачу проблеми
Чому це питання там може бути не
вирішене тобто я бачив позитивний фідбек
бачив таке В нас є певний фаст-трек коли
заблоковані медіа або блогери швидко
розблоковуються або просто користувачі
звертаються до нас Ми допомагаємо
розблокувати або вони напряму
звертаються до мета тому позитивна
тенденція в цьому напрямку є і впевнений
що також вона буде продовжуватися але
все ж таки чому в які ви чуєте аргументи
коли говорите про цифрову ізоляцію все
одно ну є способи цього всього обійти
меншого розміру компанії більшого з
нього компанії
така цифрова ізоляція зрештою ну
неможливо
повна цифрова ізоляція
Я думаю що закриття Фейсбук Інстаграм
сильно попливало на
розвиток малого середнього бізнесу це
100% на дію пропаганди тому що там вони
почали все блокувати коли мета е-е
підтримала по суті боротьбу з пропаганди
і почала відзначати державні сторінки і
блокувати контент і відзначати що це
компанії організації фінансується урядом
і це сильно впливає на взагалі доступ до
технологій на те що люди і які звикнути
технології покидають Росію тобто люди
які створюють додаткову цінність вони
покидають Росію та тим самим максимально
впливають на спати економіки на взагалі
створені новації компанії з додатковою
цінністю ось це в цьому важливість цієї
ізоляції те що хтось якось там через VPN
знаходить можливості користуватися но на
жаль Тут напевно неможливо на 100% це
виконати але на глобальне як культура
все це виходить з Росії і це відкидають
набагато років назад в цьому і завдання
великі корпорації які впливають
максимально на розвиток ВВП на створення
нових кадрів на відкриття ринків вони
виходило з Росії не В цьому плані
тенденція вона позитивна але все одно
хоче тут підтвердити що я над чим
працювати І будемо дотискати я повернуся
до вашої співпраці з військовим мєнців
реалізує масштабний проект армія Дронів
як знову ж таки як так сталося що
цивільний Міністерство закуповує техніку
для військових і в той час коли
Міноборони навколо їх самих закупівель
досить багато корупційних скандалів і
всього такого як ви цим владнаєте зараз
важлива Ремарка що ми не закуповуємо ми
акумулюємо ресурси з усього світу для
того щоб закуповували якраз там е-е
військові органи в нас немає там
рахунків навіть ми це рахунки Нацбанку
які напряму потрапляють до Міністерства
да це рахунки Національного банку які
відразу потрапляють там до різних
міністерств але мені цифру не можна
купувати і не купує БПЛА важливість
цього проекту в тому що ми по суті разом
з генштабами зміна оборони постійно
оновлюємо покращуємо доктрини введення
війни завдяки БПЛА впливаємо на розвиток
українських виробників на пошук компанії
по всьому світу на розвиток систем
ситуативної ситуаційного бізнесу Тобто
ми по суті трансформуємо
найважливішу сферу сьогодення для того
щоб
швидше отримати перемогу в цьому наше
місія Міністерство - це право
трансформація Ми беремо найбільш важливі
важливі сфери і трансформуємо покращуємо
пришвидшуємо сьогодні війна є для нас
там фундаментальною темою сферою нам
потрібно перемогти у війні І тому ми тут
робимо все що ми можемо зробити з точки
зору технології для того щоб приблизити
перемогу
кілька років працював в Україні фонд
підтримки стартапів от буквально кілька
місяців тому ви його собі підкрило взяли
і Наскільки я розумію намагаєтесь
впроваджувати через нього
е-е якраз розвиток мілітарних технологій
якихось військових у вас є вже якісь
перші непрацювання чи проекти і
скільки в державах грошей на це
взагалі-то є фонд інновації на базі
цього фонду інновації розвивався проект
фонд стартапів він став найбільшим
ангельським інвестором ми для цього було
до нього дотичні у нас там є наші
співробітники і заступник наприклад в
бордій цього фонду Ми багато часу
приділяли він розвивався але потрібно
розвиватися ще швидше і Міністерство
фінансів підтримало що логічно Якщо ми
будемо керувати цим фондом і зараз ми не
тільки збільшуємо там активність щодо
пошуку фінансування наповнення не з
державних бюджетів цього фонду що
фінансувати стартапи тому що потрібно
продовжувати розвивати стартапи світ
розвивається і українські підприємці
продовжують розвиватися але для нас дуже
важливо окремо на базі цього фонду
інновації Ми запускаємо цілий міліталі
кластер тобто якщо у вас є ідея як
почати яку впровадження якої дозволить
нам перемогти вона пов'язана з війною
приходять тоді ми вам допоможемо
експертами грошима грантами якщо у вас є
готовий проект ми вас зв'яжемо з
міністерством оборони з генштабом вренді
допрацюємо цей проект і Також ви зможете
там держава вас буде купувати цей проект
тобто Ми створюємо екосистему де
будь-яка людина яка хоче бути завдяки
своєму підприємницькому там
інноваційному таланту дотична до
перемоги вона може прийти і отримати
допомогу е-е у нас там ну на сьогодні
там невелика кількість грошей тому що
там в перші місяці війни облігації
купували всі державні така Політика була
держави що потрібно всі всі гроші
повинні були йти на
нашу перемогу Але в цьому
році вони будуть повертатися і там мова
йде трохи більше ніж 100 млн грн на такі
подібні проекти на гранти Тобто
мілітерітек - це можливо майбутнє нашої
цифрової економіки ми війна найбільш
технологічна яка зараз відбувається в
світі найбільша війна часів Другої
світової війни вона відбувається в
країні де 300 000 айтішників в країні де
активне покриття інтернетом де є певна
цифрова культура нам допомагає весь
цивілі єдиний світ
війна максимально технологічна і тому
тут будуть народжуватися проекти які
будуть ставати на озброєння інших країн
найближчі 20-30 років Вам не здається
побоютесь то що ввечері фінансування от
власне в іншому модель фінансування під
час війни коли заощаджується кожна
копійка Ну буде неефективно Я вважаю що
тільки модель венченого інвестування
може призвести нас до перемоги якщо ми
говоримо про мілітаритет тому що якраз
таке поле активносте відбувається що
потрібно давати можливість різним
підприємцям для того щоб вони
впроваджували в життя свої проекти Тим
паче що мова йде не про 100 мільярдів
нести про 150 мільярдів навіть не про
мільярд мова йде про ті гроші які можуть
дозволити виникнути продуктам які
змінять хід війни і це може зберегти
десятки життів
сотні життів можливо тисячі життів тому
що навіть один Малік три тест
тепловізорам він може врятувати там за
один день кілька або десяток життів якщо
ми говоримо про ударні випила які можуть
там використовувати
народжуватися які можуть е-е розбивати
танки реп а це вже про інновації
говоримо або пила які знаходять реп і
е-е його ліквідують Всім займалося
конструкторське бюро структуру
укроборонпрому свого часу розробляли
новітні озброєння впроваджував якісь
технології чому пряма фінансова
підтримка КБ типу чи навпаки залучення
людей до цих КБ
пошук кадрів для них не не є такою
ефективною моделлю на вашу думку я не
керував цими структурами тому мені важко
коментувати якось характеризувати Це я
просто дивлюся те що відбувається в
світі теж дарпа наприклад США Я бачу як
розвивається взагалі технологічний світ
я бачу Ну ми в рік вже в масштабній
війні і я добре розумію що відбувається
на кожній ділянці фронту які
технологічні засоби українського
виробництва де ється і я бачу в кого
вийшло вийшло в тих хто не був взаємодії
з державою
Хто отримав швидке фінансування для
реалізації своїх божевільних ідей ось
цих вийшло Я не хочу просто проводити
державні приклади Ну тому що ми все-таки
війна і я держслужбовець але я
взагалі держслужбовець на війні і не
хочете підтримувати державні
підприємства впевнений що потрібно дати
свободу підприємцям Вони все зроблять це
має тверда позиція
рік тому трохи більше дали свободу
підприємцям ще однієї галузі яка тепер
підващує опікою це гральний бізнес ви
тепер будете ними теж опікуватися я
просто ну ви так багато всім займаєтесь
Вибачте що в мене питання просто з
різною справою говорити про будь-яке
питання яким я займаю- займаюся тому що
це люблю цим займатися
за останні просто два тижні навколо
грального бізнесу і кілька скандалів
доповідь СБУ на парламентському комітеті
санкції проти найбільшого гравця на
цьому ринку що розкажіть пішло не так на
вашу думку з реальним бізнесом Я вважаю
що не була створена прозора система без
людського фактору яка дозволила всім
компаніям працювати е-е в різних умовах
і сплачувати податки тобто питання ну
неважливо
що там відбулося сьогодні або вчора це ж
саме відбудеться через півроку рік два
роки три роки п'ять 10 100 якщо не
змінити правила в мене є чітка позиція і
бачення що потрібно зробити в цьому
напрямку якщо парламент це підтримує Я
готовий взяти на себе відповідальність
що це буде одна з найбільш прозорих сфер
в нашій країні Я вважаю що потрібно
змінити податкового агента і зробити щоб
податки з грального бізнесу знімалися
коли тільки потрапляють на рахунок
відразу щоб не було сплати після цього А
з кожною транзакції банк з автоматично
відразу в бюджет відправляв гроші
платити моя гравець Я вважаю ну це
казино сплачує гральний бізнес але
відразу а не через деякий час занижені
податки і без людського фактору повністю
Я вважаю що потрібно ліквідувати комісію
гральну і є вона не потрібна Якщо є
чіткі правила навіщо як стати отримати
ліцензію всю я бачу можна перевірити в
реєстрах там де суб'єктивна оцінка там
виникає ситуація з хабарями також я
вважаю що потрібно дати Агентство яке що
повинно або створитися замість або
трансформуватися в комісія можливість
закривати сайти які працюють без
ліцензії дуже швидко в кілька кліків і
не потрібно там писати листи також які
потім не приймаються ці рішення і так
далі І також потрібно там зробити такі
рішення це один із прикладів бот а який
автоматизовано купує на у всіх
ліцензіатів або і у всіх сайтах на всіх
сайтах робить невеличкий транзакції для
того щоб дивитися А куди потрапляють ці
гроші чи на той рахунок і на який
отримав на ліцензію прив'язаний до цього
бізнесу ліцензіато тобто ідея наша в
тому що взагалі прибрати людські фактор
Я не вірю що можна побудувати якусь
інституцію з судженнями е-е
людськими яка буде не корумпована в
цьому напрямку Я вважаю що потрібно
будувати суд автоматизовану систему без
де не приймає людине рішення я щось
приблизно таке чув мабуть років 11 чи
вже 12 то тому коли почали говорити про
податкові пільги для
it галузі це проект який впроваджувались
12-го року ще з президентства Януковича
і тільки Вам вдалося запустити цей новий
механізм дія Сіті Ось він вже рік
попрацював
збільшили податкові надходження
яка
зростає можна це пов'язати чи ні але
вона продовжує зростати і за ми
запустили цей проект за два тижні
певно-масштабного вторгнення 35 тисяч
людей інкрипорувалися в дія Сіті і
перейшли з фопів на трудові відносини що
в принципі було цілі і ми запровадили
елементи вечірнього інвестування під час
війни вторгненням повномасштабного
влітку Харківська компанія залучила
інвестиції по суті продалася компанія
який продовжує працювати в Україні але
лондонськими інвестиціями з Англії тобто
Мені здається що цей проект е-е йому
тільки рік але він показав результати ну
досить потужні в нього є дуже
перспективно цікаво в інкубаторна якась
така складова частина залучення
інвестиції але все ж таки надавати під
час війни коли заощаджується кожна
копійка і я вже Повторюю це не перший
раз
давати комусь такі суттєві податкові
пільги чи Це доречно було Та тут є
чіткам математична модель яка говорить
що Це доречно там ще трохи часу і це
показано по якому сценарію моделі ми
рухаємося Але
я вважаю що коли в нас громадяни
сплачують до 50% податків грошей які
вони отримують це просто неможливо
неможливо зробити щоб всі сплачували
такі великі податки всі країни які
зробили Стрибок у своєму розвитку якщо
проаналізувати нам Сполучені Штати і
будь-яку країну вони починали з того що
створювали інклюзивні інститути які
працювали я на жаль на це не можу просто
впливати Ну там я не займаюся судовою
сферою або щастя напевно тут садової
сферою правоохоронною і так далі І це
звичайно що зрозумілі податки для того
щоб компанії могли по-перше сплачувати
біла по-друге реінвестувати свій
прибуток тому на it галузі ми по суті і
намагаємося показати модель як компанії
можуть відбілювати свої відносини
всередині переходити з оптимізації в
Білу працювати Вони всі в штатний мають
Зараз в нас є там така компанія
наприклад Аякс ну це там всі знають А як
там встановлюють багато людей вдома В
себе охоронні системи 100% співробітника
перевела в технологічну компанію
перевела в штаб і пішла з того
досягнення А я ну звертаю на це увагу що
багато років Вони дали у державу
Дивіться це підприємці завдяки котрим в
принципі функціонує держава створюється
робочі місця я взагалі про підприємців і
дурити но не погоджуються з цією думкою
Я вірю що підприємці це рушії
розвитку будь-якої країни це кров
України і потрібно створювати для
підприємців умови в яких вони будуть
розвиватися дурити підприємці створюють
робочі місця і забезпечують розвиток
України створювали робочі місця Я ж кажу
в цій історії понад 10 років і кожного
разу коли вона спивала вони казали от
якщо ви не дасте нам пільги то ми
програємо світові ринки Ми не можемо
створювати ранкові місця правда Якщо
якби вони сплачували податки на 100%,
вони б не були конкурентні в світі
маржинальність просто би не виходило аби
була менша вони не змогли реінтестувати
На сьогодні це там вже стало найбільше
експортна галузь завдяки тому що вони
оптимізовували податки А ми сказали
дивіться не потрібно ламати те що є Вони
зараз на півтора відсотки більше
податків все одно сплачують Тому що нема
Ну ми додали військовий збір вони не
сплачували його але вони почали
працювати в білий почали відчувати себе
гідно і вони почали переводити людей в
штат і вони почали реінвестувати
запускати нові проекти і вони під час
вторгнення зараз багато іт-компаній
знаходяться тут вони продовжують
працювати вони продовжують ви дивіться
е-е будь-яку будь-який сайт пошуку
роботи скільки там вакансії атішник
тобто я вірю в підприємців вважаю що
завжди потрібна повинна створювати
прозорі зрозуміли правила гри розуміючи
ринки які вона розвиває і тоді не буде
Цього поняття хтось когось обдурює оце
виникає тільки тоді коли держава не
створює інструментів окдує вас бентежить
що тут є певна соціальна професійне
несправедливість Чого Ну давайте-далеко
там не ходити наприклад чому я сплачую
19,5% податків а Мої колеги з генезісу
які так само займаються редагуванням там
Вибачте за приклад голови сплатять 6,5
Ну я взагалі не побі знаєте щоб був
сусіда була гірше Я думаю податки Вони
люди рівні перед законом Я вважаю що
така податкова система повинна бути для
всієї країни А в мене було два варіанти
або сидіти і просто так вважати а другий
варіант показати на эти галузі що це
математична економічна дала результат і
щоб фінансовий комітет податковий там
Міністерство фінансів звернули на це
увагу і
прийняли найкраще в світі податкову
систему для наших громадян які є так як
заслуговуєте щоб сплачувати найкращі
подати податки в світі а не такі великі
е-е при такому рівні ВВП все-таки це не
єдине ваше поступка для галузі ви з
осені
просували ідею з
більш вільним виїздом айтішників
спеціалістів чоловіків за кордон зараз
президентство в дії Сіті є однією з
підстав для бронювання як стратегічної
галузі Я так розумію
все-таки Вам не здається що ви Ну типу
створюєте якусь
правовійовану касту точніше не створюєте
вона такою вже і є в країні Просто ви
цементуєте ну по-перше це відноситься
просто до політики якої формує е-е
Міністерство наприклад культур
інформаційної політики напевно Може
також боротися і за розвиток вашої
галузі Де ви працюєте І це нормально що
ми намагаємося розвивати той напрямок За
який відповідає а я вважаю що
окрім цього що я відповідаю за цю галузі
намагаюся бути робити все що можна щоб
наша країна була розвивалася виноватцях
Я вірю в технологічній компанії вірю що
за ними майбутнє ВВП що економіка стане
цифровою що в нас з'явиться більше не
аутсорственної компанії продуктових ну
дай боже ауксорственно нехай
розвивається але буде більше продуктових
я я вважаю що нам потрібно більше
мільярдна компанія е-е щоб вони
коштували стільки щоб вони залучали
увагу гроші інвестиції з усього світу і
майбутнє за технологія на 100%. і
потрібно в цьому напрямку максимально
швидко розвиватися Ось я і е намагаюся
все зробити щоб побудувати цифрову
державу і наша команда намагається це
зробити
привілевий - це частини цього процесу
так найкращий в світі умови для розвитку
які галузі Я хочу створити я я цим
пишаюся Я хочу створити найкращі умови в
світі для розвитку я тягалося
Окей дякую мене все дякую вам